>> Bret: OUR TOP STORY AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE HOUR, THE ACCUSED
SHOOTER IN YESTERDAY'S FLORIDA
SCHOOL MASSACRE MADE HIS FIRST
COURT APPEARANCE THIS AFTERNOON.
19-YEAR-OLD NIKOLAUS CRUZ IS
CHARGED WITH 17 COUNTS OF
PREMEDITATED MURDER.
MANY OF THOSE WHO SURVIVED ARE
BEING TREATED AT A HOSPITAL IN
POMPANO BEACH.
THAT'S WHERE WE FIND CHIEF
NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT ED HENRY
WITH THE LATEST.
GOOD EVENING, ED.
>> Reporter: BRET, GOOD EVENING.
IF THERE'S EVEN A TINY BIT OF
GOOD NEWS TONIGHT AMID ALL THIS
TRAGEDY, IT'S THAT THERE'S ONLY
ONE PATIENT LEFT IN CRITICAL
CONDITION TONIGHT, AND THAT IS
REALLY A MIRACLE, GIVEN THE
TRIAGE THAT WENT ON BEHIND ME.
AS THE HORROR BEGAN PLAYING OUT
AT STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL,
THE DOCTORS AT THE HOSPITAL
INITIATED A CODE GREEN.
ALL HANDS ON DESK DISASTER
ANNOUNCEMENT THEY TRAINED FOR
JUST SIX MONTHS AGO, YET NOTHING
FULLY PREPARED THEM FOR THIS.
>> WE KEPT ON GETTING PHONE
CALLS, ARE YOU READY TO RECEIVE
MORE PATIENTS?
ARE YOU READY TO TAKE THAT ONE?
>> Reporter: THE DOCTORS HERE
BELIEVE THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN
FAR MORE DEATHS BUT FOR THE
REMARKABLE WORK OF THE EMERGENCY
PERSONNEL WHO STOPPED THE
BLEEDING ON SO MANY WOUNDS.
>> A COUPLE MINUTES I SAID, WOW,
THIS IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
THIS IS REAL LIFE.
>> Reporter: THERE WAS ALSO THE
BRAVERY OF ONE OF THE FIRST
VICTIMS WHO WAS IDENTIFIED,
AARON FEISS, ASSISTANT FOOTBALL
COACH AND SECURITY GUARD WHO
USED HIS OWN BODY AS A HUMAN
FROM BEING SHOT.
>> WE HAD AN ATHLETIC DIRECTOR,
CAMPUS MONITOR, WHO RESPONDED
IMMEDIATELY WHEN THERE WAS SIGNS
OF TROUBLE IN THE SCHOOL.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE TWO HEROES
GAVE THEIR LIVES FOR OUR KIDS
AND PROBABLY HELPED PREVENT THIS
FROM BEING A WORSE TRAGEDY
TODAY.
>> Reporter: STUDENTS WHO
SURVIVED THE BLOODSHED GIVE
GREAT CREDIT TO A JANITOR WHO
SAVED DOZENS OF LIVES BY
REALIZING WHEN THE SHOOTER
PULLED A FIRE ALARM, A LARGE
GROUP OF BARRICADED STUDENTS
WERE HEADED RIGHT AT HIM.
>> AS A RESULT OF THEIR HEROIC
ACTION, THEY SAVED PROBABLY ALL
OF OUR LIVES, ABOUT 40 OF US.
>> Reporter: THE 19-YEAR-OLD
SHOOTER WAS ORDERED HELD WITHOUT
BOND, AFTER A BRIEF HEARING.
>> ARE YOU NIKOLAUS JACOB CRUZ?
>> YES, MA'AM.
>> OKAY, SIR.
YOU ARE CHARGED WITH 17 COUNTS
OF PREMEDITATED MURDER.
>> Reporter: MEANWHILE, PEOPLE
IN THIS SHATTERED FLORIDA
COMMUNITY TRIED TO COME TOGETHER
WITH AN AFTERNOON VIGIL, TO TRY
TO HELP EASE THE PAIN OF SO
MANY, LIKE THIS GIRL WHOSE BEST
FRIEND WAS SHOT RIGHT NEXT TO
HER.
>> UNFORTUNATELY SHE DIDN'T MAKE
IT.
>> Reporter: NOW, WE SHOULD NOTE
THIS IS ONE OF TWO HOSPITALS IN
THE BROWARD HEALTH SYSTEM THAT
HELPED OUT.
ALL TOLD, WHEN YOU COMBINE BOTH
HOSPITALS, THERE'S THAT ONE
PATIENT I MENTIONED IN CRITICAL
CONDITION.
THERE'S NOW SEVEN PATIENTS IN
FAIR CONDITION, AND ONE TONIGHT
IN GOOD CONDITION.